So let's talk about some battleground States
for 2020 right now because we've got to be
honest,
very rarely are presidential elections decided
by who wins, Massachusets or how big a margin
of victory the Democrat has in California.
Those things influenced the popular vote.
But of course, we have an electoral college
system in the U S so reality check time. Tomorrow.
We will talk about how in national polls,
Donald Trump is way, way, way down, uh, in
hypothetical matchups against Joe Biden by
17 points against Elizabeth Warren by 16 points
against Bernie Sanders by 14 points. But do
we believe that Donald Trump is going to lose
the popular vote by 1516 or 17 points in 2020?
I don't think so. It would be historic. It
wouldn't be impossible, but it would be historic
and we haven't seen anything like that for
a very long time. So if we assume that the
popular vote nationally is going to tighten
up as we get closer and closer to the election,
the most likely scenario is that a few key
battleground States are going to decide 2020.
So I think it's a logical time, less than
a year out from the election at this point
to start looking at who have the democratic
front runners is doing best in those States.
And right now it is not Elizabeth Warren.
Now, of course, I know that there's a constant
discussions over, am I a Bernie bro? Am I
a Warren shill or whatever? I'm not any of
those things. I tell you what the facts are
and what the polls say. A new New York times
poll looked at six important States. Those
States are Michigan, Wisconsin, Florida, Arizona,
and North Carolina in hypothetical match-ups
against Donald Trump in those States. Joe
Biden is winning four States. Bernie is winning
three and Elizabeth Warren is winning only
one Arizona right now, according to state
polls, Biden would defeat Trump in Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Florida and Arizona, but lose North
Carolina and they are tied in Michigan. So
that's four for Biden.
Bernie right now would beat Trump in Michigan,
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin, but with lose
to Trump in Florida, Arizona and North Carolina
and Warren is leading Trump and Arizona losing
in Michigan, Florida and North Carolina and
tide and Pennsylvania and Wisconsin. So on
this basis, if we say electoral college, presidential
elections in the United States typically come
down to these States. Biden and Bernie are
looking far stronger than Warren, but there's
actually even worse news for Elizabeth Warren.
That polling was among registered voters,
but as we know, not everybody who was registered
actually votes. If you look at likely voters,
it is a disaster for Elizabeth Warren. It's
also slightly worse for Bernie, but not nearly
as much worse as it is for Warren among likely
voters. Biden wins five of these key States,
all of them from North Carolina, all of them
button North Carolina. Bernie wins just one
Michigan while he's losing to Trump and for
and Elizabeth Warren among likely voters is
behind in five of the six States and even
only in one of them Arizona.
But let's dig deeper. This is not enough.
What about Ohio? Ohio has been a big marker
for presidential elections and a big battleground.
Ohio was not included in this poll of key
States. If we look at polling in Ohio, which
is admittedly a month old at this point, Warren
is plus four over Trump in Ohio. Bernie has
a bigger lead with plus six and Biden also
at plus six. So all of the normal caveats
here, things can change between now and November
of 2020. Um, it's early. Electability is a
fraught issue. Likability as part of that
is an even more fraught issue. But as we get
closer and closer, these are going to be real
issues to talk about. Now as far as it being
early, it is early, but in the last three
presidential elections, when you looked at
polls head to head, hypothetical matchups
a year in advance, they were essentially just
as accurate as the day before the election.
So while it is early and things can change,
often they don't. And often hypothetical match-ups
at this point can actually tell us quite a
bit, quite a bit. So these numbers don't look
good for Elizabeth Warren. I want to hear
from you, what do you make of them? But the
other thing we should really be looking at
are voter cross-sections because Donald Trump's
advantage with white, particularly, uh, those
that are not college educated, continues to
be something that is truly a house of horrors
and effectively a dystopian nightmare. And
that's what I want to get into next in detail.